[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue sur tv 78 pour ce
nouveau numéro de vivre nous sommes à la
maison de l'environnement à l'occasion
d'une rencontre organisée par la
commanderie de 50 en libye notre invité
valérie masson-delmotte bonjour bonjour
vous êtes paléoclimatologue directrice
de recherche au laboratoire des sciences
du climat et de l'environnement unités
du cea le commissariat à l'énergie
atomique le cnrs le centre national de
la recherche scientifique et lui vécu
l'université versailles saint quentin
alors vous êtes présente ce soir pour
une rencontre avec le public vous
informer échanger sur le changement
climatique
c'est important pour vous d'échanger
avec le public oui et je pense que ça
fait vraiment partie de nos missions en
fait c'est à dire que la recherche
scientifique s'est pas seulement
produire des connaissances mais c'est
aussi les partager et d'autant plus que
la question du changement climatique la
rue finalement elle concerne tout le
monde de multiples manières vous écrivez
aussi des ouvrages pour les adultes mais
pour 6 pour la jeunesse vous souhaitez
vous adresser à tous alors effectivement
donc là je vais superviser un rapport
d'évaluation sur l'état des
connaissances vis-à-vis du changement
climatique donc c'est un document qui en
fait très technique qui est aussi une
construction avec les représentants de
tous les pays qui finalement
reconnaissent ce socle scientifique
commun et puis à côté de ça j'ai
intervient alors selon la disponibilité
que j'ai devant le très grand public
mais aussi parfois à la demande
d'enseignants
devant des élèves un public scolaire et
pour moi c'est quelque chose qui est
extrêmement intéressant c'est à dire le
fait de pouvoir entendre les questions
que se posent les gens la manière dont
il se représente le changement
climatique par rapport à ce qu'ils
apprennent à l'école ou bien ce qu'ils
glanent sur les réseaux sociaux dont les
médias c'est quelque chose aussi qui
parfois m'amène moi même un profond dire
méconnaissance par rapport à des
questions qui sont posées et pour
lesquels je vais solliciter des
collègues pour vraiment comprendre
l'état des lieux est depuis lors de
transmettre les lieux possibles oui puis
j'ai vous adresser quand vous adresse à
la jeunesse à ceux de demain qui vont
subir les effets de ce changement
climatique oui alors j'ai aussi un mois
deux filles qui sont maintenant
étudiants afin qu'ils sont adultes mais
c'est vrai que
quand on s'intéresse aux évolutions
futures du climat il s'agit en fait du
monde des jeunes d'aujourd'hui à horizon
2005 non mes filles auront de mon âge
donc en fait c'est quelque chose qui
n'est pas tellement lointain c'est
quelques dizaines d'années dans le futur
et donc faire en sorte que les plus
jeunes
finalement comprennent pourquoi est-ce
qu'on en est là aujourd'hui quels sont
les leviers d'action qui existent pour
vivre avec un climat qui change et puis
pour agir sur la cause du changement je
pense que c'est quelque chose qui est
important parce que le changement
climatique ce n'est pas quelque chose
qui va disparaître demain on va vivre en
paix pendant longtemps et donc du coup
c'est important d'avoir des repères
factuels
vraiment rigoureux objectif c'est
important aussi pour former des citoyens
qui ont l'esprit critique par rapport à
ce qu'on peut entendre sur sur ces
sujets alors ce qu'a fait l'actualité
c'était en septembre dernier 2021 il
était rendu le rapport du giec le groupe
d'experts intergouvernemental sur
l'évolution du climat et vous avez tout
dit super pardon à l'assemblée nationale
sur ce rapport il faut aussi rapporté au
plus haut ce que vous avez évalué oui
donc ce rapport c'était trois ans de
travail avec des centaines de chercheurs
du monde entier et puis toutes les
étapes de relecture pour s'assurer de la
rigueur de la qualité la pertinence de
l'évaluation donc c'est un travail
considérable mais c'est un travail qui
n'a de sens que s'il est partagé donc le
fait que par exemple le les commissions
spécialisées sur le développement
durable de l'assemblée nationale ou du
sénat demande à auditionner les auteurs
du rapport - en tant que coordinatrice
le fait que c'était le cas aussi au
parlement européen par exemple ou dans
certains conseils municipaux on a aussi
invité à intervenir en plus en visio
c'est plus facile ça demande un des
arrondissements
voilà je pense que c'est quelque chose
qui est important et je souligne en fait
que moi ce que j'observe c'est un
intérêt croissant sur cet état des lieux
scientifique par des citoyens des
étudiants les collectifs d'entreprise
également dans de nombreux secteurs
d'activités pour les choses changent
c'est à dire c'est pas quelque chose qui
reste dans un petit cercle académique
qui parle à des initiés on va dire mais
il ya vraiment une appétence de
comprendre non mais et puis surtout on
peut agir très large alors on va revenir
un petit peu avant tout ça parce
qu'avant d'être co présidents du groupe
1 du geiq vous êtes chercheuse
paléoclimatologue qu'est ce que c'est
alors je suis toujours chercheuse en
fait à sa clémence a rien changé le
travail qu'on fait pour le chèque c'est
non rémunérés en fait c'est un peu plus
de nos autres activités c'est à dire
mais connaître mon employeur doit
accepter je passe beaucoup de temps
pendant quelques amis à faire cela donc
on n'est pas moi j'ai une formation
d'ingénieur une spécialité en physique
des fluides et puis j'ai choisi de
travailler en sciences du climat donc
j'étais dans un laboratoire de recherche
qui m'a accueilli en stage et puis
ensuite en thèse en formation par la
recherche donc la paléoclimatologie nce
et étudier les variations climatiques
passés avant qu'on ait directement des
instruments de mesure donc en tirant
parti des indices que le climat laisse
dans des archives naturel donc j'ai
travaillé par exemple sur l'étude les
carottes de glace on pourrait nombre
dans l'antarctique ou au tibet il est
bien là on n'a pas de glaciers les
vestiges qui sont laissés dans les
anneaux de croissance des arbres par
exemple du côté de fontainebleau des
poutres bâtiments historiques et puis
des arbres des arbres ou de la nature en
parle encore aujourd'hui voilà donc en
fait il ya des choses visibles par
exemple la taille des anneaux de
croissance des arbres qui va dépendre la
température de la saison croissance ou
bien de de la sécheresse les on a des
indices moins visibles et moi ce qui
m'intéresse c'est par exemple le rapport
entre les molécules lourdes et légères
de l'eau qu'on va trouver dans la glace
et dont l'abondance dépend des
conditions de températures passées mais
qu'est-ce qui vous plaisait je vous dans
la recherche quand vous vous lancer
dedans
alors pour masquer un fascinant c'est
l'inconnu c'est à dire ne pas connaître
ces variations passées du climat est
arrivé à les reconstituer par exemple
dans les glaces de l'antarctique
on a réussi à obtenir des
enregistrements sur 800 millions donc
c'est une durée très longue une
succession de périodes glaciaires et
période douce parce que la trajectoire
de la terre autour du soleil change
graduellement c'est le moteur et puis ça
nous permet de départ décortiqué comment
les climats il réagi comment le cycle du
carbone la composition de l'atmosphère
réagi comment le niveau des marchands
quand le volume des glaces sur les
continents et vous lui en fait c'est la
même machine climatique qui réagit
aujourd'hui parce que nous perturbons le
climat à l'échelle planétaire et donc ça
nous permet de comprendre le
fonctionnement de cette machine on peut
voir les climats passés comme autant
d'expériences naturel finalement sur le
climat de la terre à plus court terme
les derniers millénaires les petites
variations récentes elles sont beaucoup
piloté par l'occurrence d'éruption
volcanique majeure leurs effets parasols
éphémère donc des périodes avec eux un
peu plus d'éruptions volcaniques simple
et plus frais les périodes sans éruption
volcanique c'est un peu plus doux au
cours des derniers millénaires donc ça
aussi c'est comme une sorte d'expérience
naturel sur le climat de la terre qui
permet de comprendre comment il répond à
ce type de perturbations et puis les
variations passées du climat c'est aussi
ce qui a façonné l'évolution du vivant
donc ça interagit avec l'évolution
spontanée du vivant ça façonne la
vitesse l'ampleur de ces changements
passés ça interagit aussi c'est le
milieu de vie des humains donc les
derniers centaines de milliers d'années
c'est l'émergence de l'homme moderne les
derniers milliers d'années c'est la
construction de deux civilisations
urbanisées sédentaires des activités
agricoles et donc ça permet de carats de
situer la perturbation cours dans le ton
nom on est vraiment sur une rupture du
fait des activités humaines c'est une
c'est une situation qui est inédite en
une telle perturbation aussi rapide ça
nous permet aussi de tester les outils
de modélisation qu'on a à base physique
modèles de climat qui nous servent à
explorer les futurs possibles on les
teste par rapport aux grandes variations
climatiques passés et pour moi c'est
quelque chose qui est déterminant dans
la confiance qu'on peut accorder à leurs
projections mais quand vous vous lancez
à dans ses recherches dans ces études
autour du climat est ce que vous
imaginez que le réchauffement climatique
prendraient une telle importance
aujourd'hui vos travaux aurait une telle
importance aujourd'hui alors moi j'étais
au lycée n quand il ya eu des
publications dans des magazines de
vulgarisation sur la surveillance de la
terre depuis l'espace les premiers
travaux de modélisation du climat en
france avec la hausse de l'effet de
serre est ce que ça pourrait donner eh
bien les premières études de carottes de
glace en antarctique du carottage de
vostok et je me souviens avoir lu cent
et ce qui m'avait fasciné c'était les
progrès les méthodes de recherche et
puis ce côté un peu verte genot est ce
que vraiment les manies t perturbe le
système climatique d'une manière
tellement considérables c'est ça faisait
partie de mes motivations ma curiosité
pour aller dans ce domaine là j'avais
aussi une curiosité pour l'archéologie
en fait l'histoire des sociétés humaines
personnel donc les choses sérieuses
règle voulait et puis effectivement donc
on fur et à mesure du temps le constat
scientifique n'a fait que sa fille née
et on vit tous avec les conséquences
d'un climat qui change dans chaque
région de manière croissante et c'est
d'autant plus important de parvenir à
expliquer ce qui provoque par exemple
des événements show extrêmes plus
fréquents et plus intenses vous déviez
pluies extrêmes plus fréquentes et plus
intenses dans certaines régions ou bien
les sécheresses également plus
fréquentes et plus intenses par exemple
autour de la méditerranée le coup de
personnes essaient de comprendre en fait
comment ces événements qui les affectent
dans leur vie personnelle et leur vie
professionnelle sont liés en fait aux
changements climatiques à échelle
planétaire et puis il ya aussi cet enjeu
de d'anticiper s'est remobilisé les
connaissances pour savoir à quoi se
préparer de sorte un intégré dans les
plans de prévention de risques dans les
stratégies d'adaptation et puis c'est
aussi important de bien caractériser ce
qui pèse le plus pour savoir comment
limiter le réchauffement climatique sur
quels facteurs il est important de jouer
l'effet cumulatif du dioxyde de carbone
il vient les faits très intense mais
cours des émissions de méthane lille
deux principaux facteurs qui agit sur le
réchauffement climatique à court et à
long terme alors le temps file je
souhaite terminer et que ça c'est en
2018 est distinguée par la revue nature
qui vous classe parmi les dix
scientifiques de l'année à cette
occasion jean jouzel dit de vous que
vous êtes dynamique intelligente et vous
disposez d'une énorme capacité de
travail vous vous reconnaissez ah oui
alors je pense que mon mari ne dirai
autres non plus peut-être que je
travaille un peu tôt mais c'était un
plaisir de travailler que jean jouzel il
fait partie des gens qui m'ont accueilli
en fait pour faire de la recherche qui
m'ont fait confiance et je pense que
c'est quelque chose qui est critique en
fait on a besoin aussi j'en parle parce
que c'est le moment des orientations par
exemple pour les lycéens on a besoin de
gens qui s'oriente vers des études
scientifiques et qu'ils vont aussi être
porteur de connaissances nouvelles de
solutions visent à vide enjeux liés aux
changements climatiques en particulier
donc on m'a tendu la main j'essaye de
temps dit tendre la main aussi aux plus
jeunes et en particulier aux jeunes
filles parce qu'on a moins bon des
relais des études techniques
scientifiques des études d'ingénieur il
ya de la place pour vous
merci valérie masson-delmotte on
pourrait vous écouter pendant deux
heures c'est la fin de celui qui vous
était consacrée et bien sûr merci à nos
téléspectateurs de nous suivre
[Musique]